الا غراب خالد اهلا بك وما ساء الخير الى
اي مدى يعتبر القرار البريطاني تغيرا
جوهريا في هذه الحرب على حد كبير الى حد
كبير لكن بشروط لماذا سنظهر سنرى على
الشاشه بعد قليل ما قدم حتى الان من
مدرعات اولا سنرى المضره على الفرنسيه اه
ام اي اكس 10
هذه المضره الفرنسيه همم ليست بالضبط هذه
همم
نعم اذا المضارع على الفرنسيه همم هذه هي
عباره عن تحمل هي قويه بانها تحمل مدفع
105 ملمتر لكنها تسير على العجلات لا
تستطيع ان تسير في كل التضاريس وغير محصنه
بشكل كافي هي همم سريعه الحركه لكن في
نهايه الامر هي يطلق عليها بانها دبابه
خفيفه ليست الدبابه اساسيه في القتال تكون
فعاله رغم انها قديمه والجيش الفرنسيه
يعمل على تغييرها الان همم ادخل همم
مدرعات اخرى لكنها تبقى فعاله ومهمه هناك
همم مدرعه اخرى همم تعهد الامريكيين همم
بتقديم عدد منها وهي اا براندلي همم هذه
همم اسف هذه المضارعه لا تملك القوه القصف
قوه المدفع التي الذي تملكه المدرع
الفرنسيه لانها تحمل فقط مدفع رشاش لكن مع
مدفع المدفع الرشاش هي قادره على هذه التي
نراها الان وهذه القذائف التي تطلق هي
صواريخ بتاعه لاستهداف الدبابات وهذه
المدرعه قادر على حمل عدد معين من جنود
المشاه يعني تقوم بالاستطلاع ما حمل عدد
من الجنود المشاه وقادر على ضرب المشاه
وعلى استهداف الادرار بالدبابات لكن وهي
ايضا تسير على سير وليس بعجلات عاديه
اطارات عاديه
وبالتالي هي تساند لكنها ليست دبابه قتال
رئيسيه ايضا الالمان همم تحدثوا عن تقديم
مركبه مشاهده قتاليه من نوع مارداريه ايضا
تحمل مدافع رشاشه وبعض القذائف وتستطيع ان
تساند لكن كل هذا يسمى بدبابات خفيفه غير
اساسيه تساند قوات المشاه كل هذا يختلف عن
ليبارا
اثنان سنشاهدها هذه الدبابه القتال
الرئيسيه في الجيش الالماني ليست الدبابه
عاديه يعني هذه يطلق عليها البعض بانها
افضل الدبابات في العالم لنكن همم يعني
همم دقيقتين هي من افضل الدبابات في
العالم طبعا المدفع يصل الى همم
120 مللي متر محصنه بشكل قوي ضد الالغام
وصواريخ المضاده للدبابات انظمه رؤيه
وعظره همم دفاع واستعداد لحتى القتال في
معارك تستخدم فيها اسلحه نوويه وكيميائيه
واكثر ما توصف به هذه الدبابه دقه اصابه
الهدف هذا الذي يجعلها ربما من افضل
الدبابات في العالم بالمناسبه في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه الدبابات الالمانيه كانت
اكثر اكثر فاعليه واكثر قوه اا واكثر دقه
من الدبابات الامريكيه اذا الالمان
بخبراتهم في صناعه السلاح صنعه هذه
الدبابه التي اعتمرها البعض واحده من افضل
الدبابات في العالم اليوم يجري حديث عن
منح البريطانين عدد من هذه الدبابات ليس
من المانيا مباشره لكن عن طريق دول تملكها
كبلاندا فنلندا وتنتظر هي اا ان يكون هذا
في اطار تحالف يقدم يقدم جميع مع مجموعه
الدول تقدم هذه الاسلحه همم الى اوكرانيا
وحتى يضمن تقدم لها تعهدات هي ايضا على
الدبابات امريكيه تحل محل الدبابات التي
يمكن ان تمنحها اوكرانيا هناك دبابات ايضا
تشالنجر اثنان وهي الدبابه الرئيسيه في
الجيش البريطاني الجيش البريطاني يفكر
الان في تسليم الاوكرانيين هذه الدبابه
وهي ايضا مدفع 120 ملم اا دبابه همم محصنه
جيدا همم
انظمه ملاحه ورؤيه ليليه واستعداد لقتال
الحوض معارك في استخدم فيها اسلحه كيماويه
واسلحه نوويه اذا هي طفره نوعيه في همم
استخدام السلاح ثقيل هجومي وليس دفاعي قد
يؤثر كثيرا في همم اي مواجهه مع الجانب
الروسي بشرط ان يكون العدد كافي وان يكون
الجانب الاوكراني مدرب عليه بشكل جيد وهذا
غير واضح حتى الان همم من حيث انتهيت
تحديدا خالد ما الذي يدفع الغرب الى
تزويده اوكرانيا بهكذا دبابات في هذا
التوقيت
في كثير ما يقال الان ان الفرنسيين عندما
قدموا اييي اي ام ايكس 10 بانهم حاولوا ان
يضغطوا على الالمان حتى يقدموا اسلحه
متطوره من نوع مدرعات وايضا لاحقا ليوبار
اثنان للجانب الاوكراني انا اعتقد ان هذا
الكلام غير مقنع كثيرا المانيا فرنسا
بريطانيا هولندا هذه الدول كلها جزء في
حلف الاطلسي ان قدمت احدى الدول السلاح
وكان هناك تداعيات لتسليم هذا السلاح بان
يكون رده فعل روسيه كل الحلف الاطلسي
سيكون معنا بالامر وبالتالي لابد من
موافقه الراس الكبيره اداره القي هذا
العليا في حرف الاطلسي طبعا هذا ليس بشكل
رسمي الدول التي تقود حلف الاطلسي بشكل
عملي هي الولايات المتحده لابد ان تكون
هناك موافقه امريكيه تنسيق امريكي تنسيق
بين كل هذه الدول كل هذه الاسلحه لا تقدم
هكذا هناك تنسيق في الغالب ما بين هذه
الدول على تقديم نوعيه السلاح
توقيت تقديم هذا السلاح وبالتالي عندما
نسال عن السبب الان لابد ان نعرف ما الذي
تريده الولايات المتحده ليس بولندا لان
حتى الولايات المتحده التي ستعود بنده
الدبابات التي يمكن ان تقدمها وليس
بالضروره المانيا التي يجب على ان توافق
على تسليم هذه الدبابات ليبارا اثنان لان
هذا دبابات المانيه لكن في النهايه المحرك
الاساسي هو الولايات المتحده لماذا
الولايات المتحده تريد هذا الان الولايات
المتحده كانت تريد ان يتم مفاوضات بين
الاوكرانيين والروس في مرحله ما لكنهم
سمعوا شروط الروسيه شروط الروسيه ان تقبل
اوكرانيا ب- همم سيطره روسيا على المناطق
الاربعه التي ضمتها اليها وطبعا هذا معناه
انتصار سياسي
لروسيا في هذه الحرب وهذا مرفوض امريكيه
واخرانيا وبالتالي يبدو ان القرار
الامريكي هو تغيير الموازين على الارض على
الارض يعني معركه الربيع الجميع يعلم ان
روسيادون لهذه المعركه والاكرانيون
يستعدون لهذا المع وبالنسبه للجانب
الامريكي يجب ان تحقق هذه المعركه نتائج
مال موسى على الارض حتى تحقق نتائج سياسيه
لماذا لان نحن الان 2023 العام المقبل
هناك انتخابات امريكيه
ان لم تتحقق نتائج سيكون هناك حاله من
الجمود في الاشهر المقبله وبعد ذلك تدخل
الولايات المتحده اجواء الانتخابات
لقد يتاثر العمود الفقري لهذا التحالف
المواجهه روسيا ومستقبل هذه الحرب قد
يتاثر بالتالي لابد ان تكون هناك نتيجه
ونتيجه ايجابيه لانه طبعا سلبيه سيكون
اراده الفعل كثيرا على اوكرانيا ومن هنا
يتم تزويد الاوكرانيين همم
تقبل الولايات المتحده بها من قبل حتى
يكون هناك تغيير وتغيير يقنع الرئيس بوتين
انه في النهايه لابد من الجلوس الى طاوله
باسرع وقت ويكون هناك استعداد لقبول
بالاهداف السياسيه الاوكرانيه ومن هنا
تحاول تجد مخرج لهذه من هذه الحرب كل
الشكر جزيلا لك خالد الغراب لي كنت معنا
في فقره وقفه مع الحدث اهلا بك اهلا بك